foreign
award back in 2007 I thought that was it
that was the highest point in my life
I eventually made a choice to drive
software development as my full-time job
and this year I changed my domain to
cloud computing simple learn scores
helped me make the switch and get a new
job with a hundred percent salary hike
hey I'm Jorge Barbosa I live in Georgia
USA with my wife two sons and two dogs
I started off as a video editor and
producer in Venezuela I even started my
own company there
in 2006 I work as one of the producers
and writer for the short music video
Bena Mikasa esta Navidad
the video got me the Latin Grammy Award
in the best video category for the year
2007.
my life was all set I shifted to the
United States with my wife and son in
2008 as a president with special
abilities
the first two years were really hard
there was no work I have to start from
scratch I landed some projects but those
were not enough
to survive I have to make some hard
decisions I have done some software
development in Venezuela
so in 2011 I got a job as a software
developer over the years I fell in love
with my professional
so last year to advance my career I made
another choice to upskill myself with
simple learns cloud computing bootcamp
in association with Caltech ctme there
were is really moving towards Cloud
technology and I wanted to have a
professional certification in the same
the course proved to be very beneficial
I completed the course in June this year
and within three weeks I got hired as a
cloud engineer and my salary just
doubled I got the job because of the AWS
and Azure technologies that I learned
during the course
professional I have not given up on my
passion for video production
it was hard initially but my work
eventually got me recognition and
acknowledgment since then I have worked
on several short videos and films like
the case against Mr Shepard verified
music in there and many more
my Mantra is never give up always try to
become better and keep your eye on the
price
[Music]